one of the things that i read about you
was that you worked in a sand
mine when you were young that you dug
sand
all day yeah that was growing up
um i was 10 about 10 years old
when i started that because i was in the
village and
where where i grew up after my leaving
my end house
i went to my grandma and we had to like
do something you know we had to work to
contribute at home
to buy oil to buy food and also
for our scholarship for books so
we have to do you have to work and
that's how we started even though you
that
work was meant for adults
but we didn't have any options so we
take what we had
at the time growing up doing something
like that
that's got to first of all it had to be
very difficult
like digging sand yeah it's also your
body
must develop very strong from doing
something like that
at 10 years old like as you're growing
as you're maturing doing something
that's that difficult
i mean it must have made you really
[ __ ] strong
uh yeah i i hope so
but what i was obviously it did but it's
just genetics too
there's a lot of good things that that
came your way that way but but also the
difficulty of doing something when
you're that young
such hard labor i mean it had to teach
you discipline there had to be like some
posi
it's terrible that you had to do that at
ten yeah there had to be some positive
aspects of it some positive
repercussions of it oh definitely
i mean i didn't like
like my life and i felt
i always feel like i miss my childhood
like
it's something missing in it because
it's been
too much uh frustration in my life
you know like i had to work by that age
and it wasn't enough like when the
school when school started
when school starts all the time i gonna
go
to school and most of the time still
didn't have a
pen to take note or a notebook to write
on it
sometimes no shoes or clothes
just have to wear like my uniform was
tear
all although all over and
i was frustrated to look around and see
other kids
looking good you know they went to the
va they went in vacation to
this family member came back with all
brand new stuff
and i was just there looking crappy with
my
i have to i had to like take my old book
and look for
empty page to take a note expecting
hoping that when i have a book
i will copy the note from this year in
the new book but at first i have to use
the
i always had to use the old book
and most of the time teachers they don't
understand why
you don't have a book they don't
understand why you don't have a pen
sometimes they just think that you
didn't tell your parents
you should tell your parents
so they can buy it for you they don't
understand that you can
not just afford it you know your parent
can't
and they'll kick you out from the
classroom
maybe just to say go tell your parents
and
and you couldn't tell them we can't
afford it you didn't want to say it
then they knew
what can they do nothing you know
because most of the time
it's gonna be even with the money that i
work that they're gonna buy my pen or my
book
but uh you work sometime and they don't
pay you right away
it's maybe after month months
you know so all the process and
sometimes they will just kick you out
from the school
because of the um scholarship
fee you have you haven't paid on time so
they kick you out so i was a subject
i was subject of shame to other kids
yeah you know because all the time when
they kick you out
in front of 50 60 uh
student it's not a good thing you know
and i couldn't have a friend because you
know how
things work you have to be able to
bring something on the table to uh
enjoy you know but since you don't even
have a pen or a book to tell no
to take note nobody expect you to
uh bring a lunch
lunch or to buy something uh in the
break break time to share with them so
they don't want to share with you
since they don't have any hope that you
will have something to share with them
and i was always in retreat i always
stay in retreat and that's how i
technically grew up by myself i end up
like not even trying to have a friend
i'm like okay this is my situation maybe
i just
i feel uh okay just retreat myself
not just to try all the time i get shame
of it all the time
you know i always i retreat and don't
have to deal with these people
with their opinion on me and
but that motivated me at some point i'm
like
tim look this kid they're looking at me
like i'm i was nothing but
technically i was more than them because
i'm working you know even though what i
have
is less than what they have
i deserve what i have i work hard for it
and they don't do
they don't work they don't deserve [ __ ]
they are just a kid
right they work and their their parents
provide
for them i'm not just lucky i'm
not just lucky to have the chance but
i'm still trying
which means i'm not bad at the end of
the day
you know so that's that
pushed me to like from there
i wanted something to prove them wrong
i'm like okay i cannot do something that
can approve this kid that
i'm not beneath them so that gave you
motivation yes that gave me motivation
because
that frustration i was full of
frustration
and i want to like drive this into
something like
i have to prove them i can't go to the
party
i can be between i can have friends as
anyone and i have to work hard than
anyone
you know my school
was like my
middle school was i think
about six miles
from home so it took me almost two hours
to get at school
she worked yeah so i worked around about
two hours
and before i met the first student
is at least after like 40 minutes
work you know so i have to wake up at
five
just get ready start work sometime
with not not eating then i get to school
and the school uh closed at maybe
four to five but since i didn't eat in
the morning
uh by noon one or two i'm hungry i'm
starving
i can't take it anymore i would leave
school sometime
you know just because i was hungry
uh if i if i have a chance if i had a
chance to
have breakfast or something i want it
before i leave home because i know if i
eat at five or six
i'll get hungry early i'll take it at
school
so it may be around 10 so i can
resist until the end you know and that's
how i i did it my um
this entire time so my um
my process was all different for from
other kids
and nobody could have understand that
you know he was just on me and i was the
only one knowing
what i'm dealing with exactly to get
there
so and all those things keep kept
frustrating me i'm like i can show this
i'm going gonna show them like how long
did you have to work in these uh sand
mines
until i left school until i finally i
left school i was 17
and then i kept doing it and then so you
did it from 10 to 17 you did it all
through school
yeah and what that was the only thing to
do right
when did you do it like if you went to
school during the day when did you work
in the sand lines
over the weekend over the holidays
i never uh have a chance to go to i
never had a chance to go to holiday
even for the summer a holiday which is
like three months
that would be because we have a tropical
climate
so at that moment we have two seasons
wet season and dry season and that's a
wet season
so it's almost rain all the time kids go
to vacation
and all those stuff adult
doesn't want to work because it's
raining all the time
guess what that was our opportunity
when they don't want to work so we have
a chance to work
otherwise they will come back to their
job we will not have job
right you know so that was a good
opportunity
to work under the rain all the time like
get back home
shaking because all day long it's been
raining so you have to stay active
because because as as soon as you stop
working moving you get cold you just get
phrasing
so you get active it force you to stay
active and to work even more
and our employer will love that because
you work even more than
normal and yeah
so that's how we we do it
and sometimes after school i will stop
at the sand mine
if i have like a quick job maybe if
a truck comes and uh they have to load
it
if i have a place to load because you
load they give money to share
you get something sometime sometime not
and when i was a kid most of the time
they kick you out
i don't didn't want you on it i'm like
hey get away off you
you know because the less there more
money they get
so they don't want you to [ __ ] around
really
i i saw that you went you went back
recently
and you're taking photos of you in the
sand mine where you worked as a boy
did i see that on instagram yeah what
was that like
i always do that yeah yeah
i mean when i'm home i always like to do
that
it's kind of like he really
hurts me to remember
everything like where i came from
how he was you know every time that i
get when i
that i go back home i will go back to
those all those places that i used to
work there i i hated this thing growing
up
oh you can imagine i hated the sun mine
everything
i hated my life but today
it seems like a fuel for my life today i
have to feel it if you're up from that
life go back there see this because most
people there
as the people that we grow up together
and he allows me to see how far
i came from you know like
i think it's the the moment that i enjoy
the most
is like those moments you know going
back
go to my uh the house that i grew up
into even though we fix it today is not
the same
but the environment like sleeping have
all this nostalgic
uh wake uh at five o'clock all these
animal sounds from outside the bed the
bed
beds all those sound was which is like
very familiar
bring you back from 20 to 25 years ago
the smells everything reminds
you something and this always
my best moment like i can go there and
live in the five-star hotel do some
crazy stuff but he doesn't
i don't i don't enjoy that as much
like i don't know how to explain it but
i always do it like i always go back to
the sun mine
this is like a tradition not just for
them
because he hurts me i like it
i feel like okay you know it's kind of
like taking my
revenge of life like okay i used to be
here
thinking this thinking that dreaming of
this dreaming of that
today i have this look that's my car
look that's my truck
yeah look that's my house look this is
my life
i'm gonna fly back to america even
though i'm here
you know yeah so it's like living a
dream
yeah because back then that was just a
dream a crazy dream
unbelievable so i'm living into it right
now like
yes doing this 20 years ago i was
dreaming like
man how it is to be in the airplane
going somewhere
imagine yourself being the airplane
going to america or
to france or something wow and
i go back i do the same [ __ ] i'm like
guess what
i'm going back to america in one week
right you're living the dream yeah yeah
and so it just
just reminds you just puts you back in
that place
yeah and uh what is crazy
is like most of the time is going to be
with the same guy that i grew up with
they are in the same place doing the
same thing and
what is it like for them do they ask you
questions like
man you know
and that's why i feel uh very lucky
just to have a different mindset just to
even have a dream
because they don't even have a dream
most of those people like
if you ask them like okay what do you
what is your dream what where would you
like to be in like
one years five years from now he doesn't
know
he gave up long time ago he doesn't give
a [ __ ] about it
as soon as as long as he has something
to eat
uh before go to bed it's okay that's it
and now i'm like how can somebody live
like this
right but it's your life you can't do
anything
i'm like but then you will find some
one some people uh which is a little
different
they are like they have a dream they are
hoping to
change their life those people over
years you can see the change in their
life
improvement step by step like this year
they're gonna say ah i want to do this i
wish i can do this
next year guess what even though they
didn't do that
they didn't get that done they get
closer and
next year and next year and next year
they move up but those who doesn't have
a dream
you know they're just there like that do
you find some
of the people there that do have a dream
look at you and they get inspired they
say oh yeah
yeah those who has and they and i think
that's
um even where um some of the reason
will keep me going back and
like even in the foundation like once
i had like a really good friend of mine
this guy is in the village and he's
doing good he's doing his businesses
doing good for a village guy like
sometimes i will come there
he'll even give me like a whiskey find a
good whiskey for me
and he said man you know like
you just going in america and come back
here
means a lot to us like we grow up
together that means it's possible for us
to
that's drive us through our dream like
motivate us like
yes if francis did it i mean
am i don't do the same thing but i can't
get to what i want to you know
and uh i'm like thank you i
i really appreciate his word and he was
like very amber
explaining me things and yeah
and that's why i also like uh doing my
foundation
like i like to like tell this kid like
listen
i'm not a a fairy tale i'm not a story
that you watch on
tv or
that you read in the book i'm in fact i
grew up here most of you
uh know me before i even i even live
here
um which means it's possible
you know as long as you believe in
something in a dream
as long as you have a dream and believe
in yourself
i think a success is just a matter of
time
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience